abbiamo finito tutto tutto esaurito
signora quelli in prima fila sono vuoti
Ma stanno arrivando Valeria Dove siete
Ahia muovetevi che forse non mi alzano
le mani a dopo ciao ciao ciao ciao ciao
signora le posso dare una sedia se vuole
senza ombrellone senza niente gliela
faccio a €60 fino alle 18:00 da mangiare
abbiamo la caprese panino prosciutto
formaggio l'insalata con la fetta come
la fetta di cosa signora la fetta al
formaggio è vegano e Nico di vegano cosa
abbiamo la frutta è vegana signora senza
glutine signora però siamo un
chiringuito sulla spiaggia non siamo un
ristorante io che cosa ne so che cosa
c'è senza glutine Nico senza glutine
Allora senza glutine abbiamo l'acqua può
scegliere tra la naturale o frizzante
oppure tutte e due sia particolarmente
fame il tè come lo vuole alla pesca non
c'è al limone neppure Nico che gusto
c'era rimasto te e il tè è rimasto solo
quello caldo signora quello con la
bustina gelati può scegliere qua sotto
dal cartello No quello non ce l'abbiamo
quella è finito quello ci deve arrivare
Eh praticamente abbiamo solo il
ghiacciolo signora Allora abbiamo detto
due bottigliette d'acqua una caprese un
ghiacciolo €78 io al prossimo